voilà la future perspectives sur la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines depuis le
parc des sources de la bièvre un projet
mené par le promoteur immobilier codic
en collaboration avec les pouvoirs
publics une opération pour remplacer
l'anneau rouges datant des années 70 par
deux bâtiments au total ce seront 25
mille mètres carrés d'aménagement qui
devrait être construit l'idée c'est de
redonner depuis le parc des sources de
la bièvre une perspective sur la gare de
saint-quentin est amené deux immeubles
de part et d'autre avec les nouvelles
caractéristiques du bureau qu'on évoque
et sur lesquels on n'arrête pas
d'innover cette opération la suite de la
construction du bâtiment native un
chantier en cours dix neuf mille mètres
carrés d'espacé huit étages au total
pour une livraison prévue en mars 2022
aujourd'hui dans les travaux qui nous
reste à faire on a deux points de
vigilance important le premier c'est à
mettre en place toute la technique qui
nous a été commandée par groupe orange
est une technique qui est à l'avant
garde de ce qui se pratique notamment en
termes de connectivité voilà donc des
technologies extrêmement poussée et puis
l'autre sujet qui est un peu en lien
avec la crise sanitaire qu'on est en
train de vivre des gens auxquels on est
extrêmement vigilant c'est toutes les
problématiques d'approvisionnement
puisque aujourd'hui on voit que sur un
certain nombre de chantiers les matières
premières manque le locataire de ce
bâtiment et l'opérateur orange les
premières équipes commenceront à arriver
en juin 2022 avec une installation
définitive en septembre 2022 au total
1200 collaborateurs travailleront ici
ce seront des chercheurs des techniciens
du réseau également des équipes de
commercialisation les équipes devront
s'organiser sur des espaces avec des
espaces très collaboratif des espaces de
concentration des espaces de détente des
espaces de réunion le but étant de
travail et gérer en mode projet ce type
d'aménagement s'inscrit dans les
nouvelles organisations des espaces de
travail cette tendance devrait être
similaire dans le réaménagement de
l'hyper centre de saint quentin en
yvelines